Are you losing marks on questions about break even?
If so, this is the only video that you need to watch
to stop losing those marks.
So Break Even Analysis wants to find out
how many products or services do I need to sell
in order for my total revenue to equal my total costs?
Because at this point
my profit will be equal to £0.
And the formula for break even is that
is equal to the fixed cost
divided by the contribution per unit.
Now the contribution per unit
also equals as selling price
minus the variable cost per unit.
So another way for writing the break even formula
is that break even is equal to your fixed costs
divided by your selling price
minus the variable cost per unit.
And an easy way to remember
this is a very on branded Christmas tip
is that Father Christmas sends presents via chimneys.
And when you calculate your break even point,
make sure that you measuring units
and that you always round up.
So for example,
if my break even point was to land an 18.2 units,
I would round up to 19 units
because I can't sell no point to a product
to a customer.
If you found this video useful,
please make sure that you are following
for more business content.